hey guys hmm back with another HD
tutorial this one's gonna be on how to
disable the Windows Vista user account
control and first off I'd say that I
only recommend this for the more
advanced users who I would say been
using Windows Vista for a little longer
and are more comfortable and familiar
with their computers so first off at the
Start menu and open up the control panel
and there will be a search box and this
applies only for Windows of course
because only Windows Vista has user
account control it up here part of the
blinking is type user user and before I
even hit enter there'll be button that
says use your accounts double click it
and there will be one here that says
turn the user account control on or off
and simply uncheck this box press ok and
you must restart before this changes
will apply so you I see pop-ups will
still happen or you restart your
computer start later if I want to turn
it back on bring right in here use it
again restart later it's a simple
estimate this will disable those
annoying pop-ups that come up say if you
want to run command prompt as an
administrator every time you see this
little icon right here that means you
need to approve it using user account
control user account control is actually
invisible to camps to do so if I were to
do that right now right click it and hit
run as administrator the window was
actually up right now and I click on it
and I'll command prompt comes up so that
is how to disable user account control
hopefully you find that tip useful and
thanks for watching
peace